The CW's Riverdale promised to sexy
updates our take on the classic Archie
comic series and a thus far the show has
delivered taking the comics central
group of teens and placing them smack
dab in the middle of a burgeoning murder
mystery Riverdale has the intrigue sass
and fun of a bonafide hit it has also
taken a lot of liberties with how the
characters appear and act compared to
the comics he is a peek at how the cast
of Riverdale should really look Archie
Andrews Archie is one of the most famous
redheads in pop culture
so of course actor KJ apper would have
to tie his naturally brown hair red for
the parts however despite the fact that
APUs pens ten hours and a salon a
struggling to get the right shade of
orange it's nowhere near as light as
Artie's hair from the comics app' is
also missing the character's signature
freckles they did the eyebrow is pretty
much perfect though of course the show
also had two CW a fire Archie a little
oh my god what game changer Archie got
hot
he's got abs now the comic version of
Archie wasn't exactly running around
Riverdale or showing off his six-pack
and while he rocks some pretty great
cheekbones and the newer Comics classic
Archie was much more of a baby face
still the show's fans don't seem to be
complaining Jughead Jones Cole Sprouse
made a huge transformation from sweet
life child star to the yangtze version
of Jughead Jones shown on Riverdale the
actor had to die his naturally blond
hair dark brown for the parts although
he keeps it slightly longer than Jughead
does in the comics still Sprouse did a
great job of adapting Jughead signature
squint and beanie the only real thing
keeping him from being a dead ringer
from the character is the nose in the
original Archie comics Jughead has a
Pinocchio style knows which Sprouse
thankfully lacks Fred Andrews Archie's
dad Fred in the comics is overweight and
nearly bald but the CW decided to give
Papa Andrews a little bit of an upgrade
casting former Beverly Hills 90210
heartthrob Luke Perry in the parts
Perry's Fred is pretty buff with a bit
of a beard and a messy hairstyle too
much
he's also definitely not sporting the
tiny moustache fred has in the comic
which is fine while we don't mind
Perry's facial hair at all a bold Perry
with a beer belly isn't really what
anybody once we feel old enough as it is
just seeing him be a dad
Sheryl blossom Sheryl blossom gets a
much bigger role in Riverdale than in
the Archie comics where she mostly just
serves as a supporting character and
further romantic rival for Archie on the
show Cheryl and her brother Jason are at
the center of the show's murder mystery
and what Cheryl knows could end up being
the key to solving the crime like her
comic book counterparts Madeline Pech is
a redhead although her hair is a bit
darker than the originals bright locks
Peck also has brown eyes while Cheryl is
usually shown with green eyes in the
comics but we're not criticizing after
all we've all seen what happens when you
end up on Cheryl's bad side
Kevin Keller Kevin is fairly new to the
comics introduced in 2010 as a series
first openly gay character in the comics
Kevin is blond as opposed to actor Casey
carts who has dark brown hair cotta also
has green eyes while in the comic
they're blue so he pretty much looks
nothing like the comic version of Kevin
he just better keep making those snarky
comments directly to the audience should
we maybe read inch making a murderer and
that flex today Betty Cooper Riverdale's
resident brilliant blonde is played on
the show by Lilly Reinhardt
who's shown she already has the
characters sweet persona down pat
however while the actress does sport
Betty's signature blonde ponytail her
hair is a little darker than the comics
yellow she also doesn't have the bangs
that Betty is usually depicted with
other than that though Reinhardt is
pretty much a dead ringer for her
classic character Veronica Lodge actress
camilla mendes said she wasn't planning
on auditioning for the part of veronica
until she found out producers were
making the character latina a departure
from a Caucasian background in the
comics Mendes who is Brazilian said she
likes that the character wasn't a
stereotype of Latinas which ended up
attracting her to the role aside from
Riverdale's change in Veronica's
background Mendes is pretty much
identical to her comic book counterparts
with the same striking beauty and dark
hair Reggie mantle
Archie's comic book rival Reggie is
played by former Disney Channel actor
Ross Butler on River
Dail changing the characters Caucasian
backgrounds to Eurasian however butlet
definitely has the slicked-back dark
hair cocky attitude and good looks to
bring Riverdale's resident bad boy
Reggie to life now if only he'd get more
screen time
Josie McCoy Riverdale made the decision
to make the entirety of the josie and
the pussycats lineup african-american
and like the comics which featured two
white characters Ashley Marie leads the
band as Josie McCoy embodying the
characters signature sass spunk and
musical talent pretty much perfectly in
the comics and cartoons
Josie is yet another redhead only she
also likes to wear cat ears and the cat
suit while rocking out naturally
Riverdale moved away from the characters
outlandish style into more toned down
fashion-forward outfits which reflects
the characters transition from sweet
girl too ambitious rocker which you know
rocks problem thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]